the Joe Rogan experience you know I was
reading this horrible story about even
after slavery was abolished one of the
things that they would do was they would
capture black men for loitering and
forced them into going into labor camps
so they would literally enforce slavery
but do slavery by having them in prison
yep and forcing them to do labor now
when I'm the reason why I bring this up
right now there was a garbage strike
garbage workers strike and so they
brought in prisoners they kicked find
out where this is they this is I don't
remember where it was but I was reading
I was like what in the [ __ ] so these
guys the garbage men made $10 an hour
they fired all the strike and garbage
men and brought in prisoners to do this
here it is prison labor replaces
striking garbage workers in New Orleans
stop and think about that they said you
know what you you want more than $10 an
hour I got a better idea we'll get
people to do it for free
so they're essentially reigniting
slavery up in New Orleans when it comes
to taking care of garbage yeah I mean
it's still real but the fact that they
think that's okay that this is like well
I got a solution yeah and the fact you
don't think someone should get more in
$10 an hour to [ __ ] take care of
people's garbage that's it's insane it's
insane and bringing in literally slaves
yeah well they shouldn't have done that
they've be paid only 13% of what garbage
makers so the garbage workers who are
only making ten dollars and 25 cents an
hour so they're gonna get 13 percent of
that which is what is that is that I got
buck fifty it's lower than that it's
like seventy five cents right it's about
a dollar
probably dollar [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean that's
just modern-day slavery it is slavery
yeah I mean giving them a dollar that's
insane
but some people would say you know
they're inmates they did wrong that's
right hold on but well go scroll back up
there listen this metro services group
has a lot
has long been an advocate of helping
persons who had been incarcerated
returned to society in a meaningful and
productive way said the city sanitation
services in a statement Metro makes no
apologies for this policy as a core
element of our commitment to being good
corporate citizens
under state rules prison inmates
employed by metro services were paid
only 13% of what garbage workers make
[ __ ] what does that mean but that is
that that is so that is so great it's
weird because there's no end of the
quotation - did it go through how long
happening oh this is happening this the
use of inmates garbage workers say they
will continue to strike in New Orleans
they have built widespread community
they've built widespread community
spreads from unions and community groups
but still that doesn't make any sense
they have built widespread community
spreads from unions and communities but
what a weird sentence from unions and
community groups but still the city has
refused to meet them and discuss their
safety concerns so they have a lot of
support from unions in the community but
they won't meet with them still OSE
they've built widespread community I
think they want to say have built
widespread community support support
yeah unions and connect groups yeah they
wrote spreads instead of support I think
and said that there they aren't trying
to hear us says woods they don't care
about us they would let anything happen
see I mean we're sick we don't care they
don't care if we spread the disease they
just don't care yeah I mean just a human
being making $10 an hour to do a
full-time job is [ __ ] insane it's
insane and a grown man in a union mm-hmm
that can't get more than $10 an hour how
[ __ ] crazy is that this is this is
what we're living in and I often wonder
you know I always think about your three
people will go and I go how long is it
gonna take how many people from us right
is it gonna take you know I'm like maybe
five maybe
six if the world is still around well
because there will always be racism some
racism not necessarily always because we
could get to a point where there we're
indistinguishable right yes I get you
they'll find another they'll find
something now I'm gonna be classism
classism or it'll be it'll be a
financial thing or an intelligence thing
you know unless unless they get to
genetic and engineering unless genetic
engineering reaches a point where
literally there is no disparity in human
beings in terms of intelligence looks
all those things but what is that going
to be like you know there's always going
to be competition there's always gonna
be weirdness right there's always you
know there's always going to be those
women that can bounce back from
pregnancy quicker there's always going
to be men like you know super geniuses
we're knuckleheads like us or scratching
our head they've been thinking that I
always think that every time I talk to
Elon every time I have that dude in here
my life isn't fair how's that fair I'm
so much dumber than him and I sit down
to talk to him it's like him talking to
a chimp like you know it's like he's
talking to a toddler but you can lift
more weights I'll [ __ ] him up he's so
much smarter than me like it's not even
close he's a large man - he's bigger
than me - he's the world's not fair
right and unless we figure out a way to
make it fair which is almost a channel
he's going to be prejudiced there's
going to be disparity
[Applause]